so this individual i was told by two
separate uh sources was um he was a
sniper for a uk trained afghan special
forces unit it's british special forces
that set up and trained and supported
commando force triple three and this man
was a sniper in that unit and
like either said he had asked for help
from a former afghan interpreter who
worked with british special forces and
is living here in the uk and he's
compiling a list or has compiled a list
of members of this triple three unit um
that are still in afghanistan in fear
for their lives
and he's given that list to the
government he gave it to the government
last night and as part of his work
speaking to different members of the
unit that are in afghanistan he was
contacted by this man who contacted
contacted him first on the 29th of
august when he
gave over his documents that showed um
that he was part of this unit and then
left the voicemail with him again on
sunday
again just saying you've got all my
documents um please make sure i'm on
your list
and like you said um we were told uh by
by this interpreter who've been in touch
with um another member of the unit who's
spoken to the family member uh that this
man was shot dead on
on monday afternoon in kabul um
they believe he was shot because of his
involvement in this unit and the concern
is that others are in danger and i spoke
to a second source who also confirmed
this man had been shot dead and um i'm
i'm here in east london at a a defense
exhibition that's going on and one of
the senior generals general sir patrick
sanders was speaking at an event earlier
and i asked him about the danger that
former members of the afghan special
forces who've been trained by the
british and other nato forces in
afghanistan about the threat that they
face and he did say that it is worrying
and that the government is doing what it
can to help those people that have been
left behind